على بعد مئات الأميال جنوب غزة، اندلعت اضطرابات
في البحر الأحمر لم نشهدها منذ عقود، حيث
كثفت قوات الحوثيين المدعومة من إيران
هجماتها على السفن التي يزعمون أن لها
علاقات مع إسرائيل، وقد أدى ذلك إلى
اضطراب كبير في الشحن العالمي مثل
شركات مثل شركة النفط العملاقة بي بي.  إعادة توجيه
السفن على طول الطريق حول أفريقيا لتجنب
الهجمات ناتاشا برتراند وريتشارد
كويست من سي إن إن ينضمون إلينا الآن
تذكرنا ناتاشا من هم الحوثيون
وكيف ترد الولايات المتحدة على هذه
الهجمات. حسنًا، جيك الحوثيون هم
في الأساس جانب واحد من الحرب الأهلية التي  لقد
كانت مستعرة في اليمن طوال
الجزء الأكبر من عقد من الزمان، والآن هم
مجموعة متمردة تمكنت من السيطرة على
أجزاء كثيرة من اليمن بدءًا من عام 2014
وهم الآن يسيطرون على جزء كبير من
شمال اليمن
ويخوضون حربًا منفصلة ضدهم.  أه المملكة العربية
السعودية على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية حرب
قامت بها آباد خلال العام الماضي بسبب
وقف إطلاق النار لكنهم مدعومون أيضًا
من إيران التي تعد بالطبع
العدو اللدود للمملكة العربية السعودية في المنطقة لذا هناك
الكثير من القوى المختلفة التي تلعب هنا
ولكن ماذا  ما تفعله الولايات المتحدة في هذه المرحلة
لمحاولة ردع أه هذه
الهجمات الصاروخية والطائرات بدون طيار المستمرة من قبل الحوثيين على
هذه السفن التجارية هو تشكيل
تحالف دولي للقوات البحرية
والذي سيكون بشكل أساسي تعزيز
الأمن في البحر الأحمر
ومرافقته عند الضرورة  الكثير من هذه
السفن التجارية حتى تتمكن من
العبور بأمان عبر جنوب
البحر الأحمر وحتى قناة السويس حيث يمر
بالطبع الكثير من التجارة الدولية
والتجارة أه بشكل
يومي الآن الولايات المتحدة تقول
أنها ليست بالضرورة  الذهاب لمرافقة
هذه السفن بشكل منتظم ولا
الدول الأخرى في المنطقة إنها في
الحقيقة مجرد أه محاولة لإظهار
للمجتمع الدولي
وصناعة الشحن الدولية أنهم
موجودون في حالة احتياجهم إليها
وأيضًا لمحاولة إظهار الحقيقة  أنهم
مستعدون للرد إذا قاموا
بهذه الهجمات الإضافية في المستقبل
ولكن بالطبع أه لم ينجح ذلك في
الماضي خلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية لقد ردت الولايات المتحدة
على هذه الهجمات الصاروخية والطائرات بدون طيار
بإسقاط العديد من
الصواريخ التي أطلقها الحوثيون  أطلقوا النار أه
لم يردعهم عن ذلك جيك